hey guys how are you I am actually quite
well because in front of me I have got a
viewmaster this is a new updated view
master by Mattel so a huge thank you to
Mattel for partnering with me on this
because this right here will not this
specific one but the original one was
one of the first choice that I feel like
ever really had a huge impact on my life
you know now I love traveling but when I
was younger me traveling was never
something that I thought was a viable
option so being able to sort of
experience the world in 3d for the first
time ever as a child this was I feel
like what made me who I am today I mean
that might be a little far-fetched to
say but I recall just sitting for hours
flicking through all of these amazing
different slides and now with the
updated view master it uses virtual
reality and your phone the virtual
reality is sort of pretty huge right now
and it's only going to get bigger and
this is such an amazing inexpensive way
to be able to use virtual reality using
your phone and it comes with a
viewmaster and it also has some amazing
expansion packs and if you don't want to
use the expansion packs physical you can
download them as expansions on your
phone so I'm a nun boxes for you guys
today and I want to hear from you guys
you remember having the original
viewmaster and what you guys think about
virtual reality in general oh I don't
have anything to open you with the only
thing that I have near me is a hanger
this'll work I can't wait any longer
like four-year-old Justine is so excited
right now I'm just saying guys you don't
know how awesome you have it right now
everything is oh I'm so excited
oh my goodness I'm sure some of you are
familiar with Google cardboard where
it's this little cardboard contraption
that you put your smartphone in and
you're able to sort of visualize and see
3d so this is kind of definitely an
upgraded version of the Google cardboard
but it uses sort of that same technology
of the split screen and oh my gosh okay
what have we got here it's like when I
was a small child oh my goodness so the
first step is a download an app it says
that you can choose from one of the
three I'm going to choose the space app
because ah you guys know I love space so
while the app is downloading I'm going
to unbox the experience packs so
currently there's three different ones
there's destinations there's wildlife
and space this is amazing this is so
cool so come to each of the little
viewmaster slides and it also comes with
these cards so these are the cards that
allow you to actually access the content
so you download the app and you use this
to unlock everything and here are your
little slide which will take you to each
different destination and adventure on
the viewmaster
this is so exciting here we've got
destinations this is great do you master
space okay so I have to insert this into
into here you just push this up right
here and then real snug a real nice fit
Hey so it's saying it do have a pass
card to unlock it so you don't have to
have the pass cards you can just unlock
this in the app if you want to buy it
hold card
here's your skin
okay whoa look at real okay whoo things
are happening this used to select
there's a little sensor inside that'll
like touch the screen
model selection gaze at a model and pull
the lever to observe it in more detail
all right space we've got
oh my rear all kinds of stuff so
unfortunately you guys can't actually
see what I'm seeing but there are things
happening so what you guys are seeing
here is what the phone is seeing your
phone shows these two images but when
you put the phone into the viewmaster
it'll split up these two images so each
of your eye will be seeing in each of
these images at the same time and with
the magic of your eyes and the
viewmaster and your brain it will form
these images into one image and it'll
allow you to sort of see in 3d it's like
I'm in like I'm in space holy moly I
just can't believe that I'm doing this
with my cell phone okay
holy crap okay if I hold this down if I
hold the button down I'm making the
spaceship move like the spaceship is
moving the spaceship is movie oh my gosh
oh this is writable
Oh what's this play me I can play a game
fun facts help jeez I can play a game
guys I'm inside the spaceship right now
I'm inside the spaceship gaze at the
buttons um I'm kind of speechless right
now because I knew this was gonna be
cool but it was actually way cooler that
I have thought it kind of actually blew
my mind a little bit because you could
do so much stuff because back in the day
if you guys a recall if you've never had
pride worthy vertical view masters when
you would use this little slide this
would make the little slides click click
click and you would be able to see
different views but it still sort of has
that same feel but this time you're
clicking around
in a virtual world and you're using your
phone like I'm using my phone to do this
I don't know why I'm so I'm just a
really cool thanks so much for watching
I will see you in the next video if you
want to get more information about this
new updated viewmaster there's a link in
the description that will hopefully
answer all of your questions and where
you can purchase it so yeah I'll see you
guys in the next vid and hope you're
awesome I'll see you in virtual reality